je sais pas qui est celle de la
merde il y arrive plutôt bien c'est toi
qui fout la merde c'est le mantois ce
qui est con dans les guerres nation
voyous c'est que c'est toujours le bruit
qui gagne c'est dommage parce que la
corsa petits besoins des nations que des
voyous
tu as laissé ses parts comme ça sans
rien demander en échange oui juste pas
plus boire
c'est à cause de moi si ces gens ont été
tués tu comprends que tu peux rien c'est
ça ma vie des gens qui tuent et les gens
qui meurent c'est comme ça s'arrêterait
jamais rendu la merde je te garantis que
tout le monde me manque les fans partie
mafiosa l'ultime saison inédite s'achève
en exclusivité sur canal+